hey guys this is dance the founder think
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the walking dead season
4 episode 15 the penultimate episode
called us ok so I actually liked this
episode it's it wasn't as good as last
week's shocking controversial episode
with Carol and the you know the the kids
but I did enjoy this one I think because
stuff actually happened and I'm also
because I'm invested in the Glenn and
Maggie relationship I was happy to see
that come to a resolution yeah I think
for me firstly I like the Epis the the
parts with Daryl and Joe with the the
hunters what everyone what we want to
call those guys with the whole thing
about claiming like playing like clean
his like I claim and nothing need all
that I i love you know that whole group
is just really interesting to me right
now even though I said last week I'm
kinda on my way out with the show but I
can still find things that I like about
the show I definitely like Daryl and the
group of the hunters with Joe as her
leader okay yeah and then with with Joe
and then there's that guy Len who they
whooped yeah open to he lied because he
he planted a rabbit yeah the rabbit so
do you think that that Joe actually saw
him plant it or he just knew he was
lying so he said that he saw him planted
yeah I think he's sees something in
Darryl that he likes coming Darryl he's
like those guys but he kind of stands
out a little bit because he has softened
his heart a little bit you know i love
the conversations at joe kept stands
like you know for he kept saying guys
like us guys like she know Hardman men
who have had to survive our whole lives
probably had rough childhoods and it's
always done we just survived we hunt we
know what to do this is how the world
just makes sense like this guys that are
just doing great in this kind of
environment I think Daryl has those
elements in him buddy you know if he
found love you know he found a family
and Rick and everybody else and so don't
think he just seems different he's
smarter than the rest of those guys and
I think Joe sees out of noon for better
for worse what say you know what's up
with the claiming stuff I mean clean
like I like it's like calling shotgun
exactly I got shotgun it's like really
it's like this is what men do make the
citizen like they say it's like calling
shotgun
actually yeah because he's like they got
all these rules right and that's like
one of the main rule like I can see that
turning to a big problem but if you lie
you get a beatin and you did get a beat
but the guy live but he got the arrow
through the eye well I died I got hell
ain't no goddamn beat dang I a little
bit more than a beatin those guys are
rough and the Darrow this I think I
don't think Darrell's like likes these
guys let's see really I think he's just
kind of got nothing else to do and he's
just like a mouse just tagging along
with these guys I got nothing else to do
yeah in the very end we find out they're
actually tracking Rick yeah I didn't
know like that was such a big deal there
with them I mean I think okay one of
their guys got killed yeah the house
yeah no I didn't know they were that
loyal to that guy that there were gonna
go track down Rick never see them walk
over the the candy wrapper candy bar
wrappers yeah um the first one I saw
that scene with Rick and Michonne I'm
like well that scene was kind of
pointless yeah it's very short yeah it's
just I mean it shows you know Carl
smiling and Michonne having a good time
and rook even shows a smile they had
like a moment of happiness in their
awful world but but then at the end it
does kind of come around and you see the
candy bar wrapper or any like oh they
are tracking I actually like that scene
with Michonne and Carl and Rick because
Michonne is a character I think that
what you know we've been critical of the
cesium but I think one of the highlights
of the season so far has been Michonne's
character because we've seen a different
side to her she isn't just the angry
pouty you know smiles she smiles and
also we learn about her backstory yeah
armor the great of a backstory about her
family and wrote her child and so this
relationship that she now has with Carl
I think it shows a better light of her
something different and just not like a
one-dimensional thing no I think the
done a great job this season with
Michonne of all the characters maybe
yeah of all the character she's probably
the one I've enjoyed the most of season
I think maybe Carol Carol two girls had
some great stories to Carol machine
repair my two favorite characters this
season just the way they flushed it
carries out Rick he's so down and just
out of it he was hurt a lot of the time
so rictus hasn't been he's not that he's
in these more he's supposed to be the
center of the group
but I think because the cast just so big
and it's a talented cast you know I
think they've just spread the load to
other characters and I think also also I
think the the showrunners and the
writers and the studio and all they
didn't expect that Darryl was gonna
become the fan favorite Darrell yeah
Darrell is the right the number one
amongst all the fans including myself
right and so they didn't expect that
right now they had their like rearranged
kind of the storylines and I like how
even a speaking of Darrell when the guy
who was killed from the hunting group I
liked when they were in the woods and
you know he got the rabbit he was like
man I got some girl giving you some
trouble and and then he went and said is
it one of them young ones and then he
saw him because I mean granted we know
you know you guys corrected me what's
the actress is 28 years old but in the
story she's I doubt she's even 18 in the
story in the story anyway so it is my
leg isn't that one of them young one
sees Darryl get really defensive about
that and because I wonder if he has hope
of finding her it seems like I just kind
of tagging along with these guys but
he's not looking for her while he's
tagging along so I wonder what his
thought processes don't know but yeah I
mean I think he's hoping to eventually
find some of the other people from his
there was own group right and that's why
at the end also besides the candy
wrapper they see the sign for terminus
yeah and joe says oh yeah that's a bunch
of BS right because like who's gonna
like be so like giving in this type of
world all right so now we get to glens
group yeah he's reuniting with Maggie
fast reuniting with me yeah well that
part wasn't so bad it was the fact that
that Maggie's group had somehow joined
with Abraham's group and like and then
came together to save Glennon Tara right
we have that clip of them on the
railroad tracks of Abraham's group and
looking at something and then all of a
sudden like Maggie shows up and then
they're all together and then it cuts
and then like there by the fire or
something at night and everybody's
together like Bob's back everybody's
just together and I'm like okay I mean
it I mean it works but it was quick you
know it's kind of a fast I'm wondering
if they they cut
some scenes like they did in that one
episode where Maggie had been lying down
on the ground just be chopped all right
right and it just was really awkward so
I'm wondering if that happened in this
episode as well like if we watch the the
blu-rays behind the scenes Louisiana
that will see like oh they actually did
meet up and right because that group of
people has never seen Maggie before
right yeah every air grew yeah right
exactly those they would at least first
think that their threats you know how
did they you know suddenly join forces
right yeah it just happened all of a
sudden but I mean you know it was nice
to think like you're saying it's been
nice to see you know Glenn and Maggie
get back together yeah cuz I'm invested
in their relationships it's one of the
relationships that I really like on the
show I liked in the beginning of the
episode when Glenn sees Maggie's uh you
know writing that they're going to
terminus right like I really like that
part and he just starts running yeah I
think it's Prince his book and be gone
yeah but then eventually they kind of
broke off that that group with the Glen
and Abraham what they reconnected pretty
pretty quickly yeah it was it was fast
but I mean it was a it was a nice little
you know this the show's become a lot
about set pieces each week has a big set
piece this big set piece was the tunnel
and Glenn going through the tunnel and
seeing all the it's almost like a video
game or a maze it's like how are we
gonna get from point A to point B how
many zombies can we kill and you know I
mean they do a good job of doing
terrifying moments and you know gruesome
action sequences and they they do a good
job on the show of that now one question
i have is where happened to that one
girls like booty shorts like the dukes
yeah she was wearing them when they
first met her right now he's wearing
regular pants or whatever yeah i mean
you know add a little like stomach
showing and all that now she's all I
conservative all like buttoned up and
everything and then of course it's funny
Abraham noticing that Tara was looking
at her you know because she's attracted
to her he's like hey I'm mad at she like
look she's hot you know Eugene looks at
her all the time so it was fun it was
some nice moments I'd yeah I liked
Eugene's dialogue he was very funny in
this episode the one thing that does
bother me and it's like a conceit of the
show it's like why would he know this
big secret of how the zombie apocalypse
started and not tell anyone right what
happens if he dies right yeah so now he
doesn't
no no no one will know and no one can
find a cure and he's the only one but he
can't tell anyone no no that's like
totally just like oh we're just doing
that because it's a show right you got I
mean you can't just put him in armor and
expecting to be safe you know he's got
to tell somebody but he's just too smart
and they resist you smart don't
understand we talking about anyway and
then they finally arrive at at terminus
which you know we can suspect is not I
haven't read the comic books past the
prison so I don't know but I'm just
guessing because it just seems too good
to be true they alluded to that with
with Joe and Daryl and it's just when
you get there it's weird this the Mary
lady that's there for me you know yeah
offering up food and they like have
water and it's too quiet yeah it's
really quiet yeah there's like nobody
there at least that we've seen yet so
it'll be interesting I mean you know
this episode 24 the fourth week in a row
now is not focused much on Glenn are
sorry I'm on Rick Carl and Michonne we
got to see Carl and Michonne but for a
brief moment it looks like next week
from the preview gonna see a lot more of
Carl and Michonne and Rick yeah we're
gonna see what goes down because we
haven't seen it seen a lot of them
unless we also haven't seen Tyrese no
Emily saw him last episode a big
shocking controversial episode but we
didn't see in this episode but a lot of
Daryl a lot of Daryl the this last month
or so yeah alright guys so that's what
we thought of the episode you can post
accountable on the website think Eric
amor on our YouTube channel think
aeropro make sure to subscribe to that
or you can check us out on Twitter talk
to DES and I about the penultimate
episode us or please chat with us about
the finale what are your predictions
we're looking forward to seeing what's
going to happen you know until you know
next year until CRI stay later this year
until season 5 we're at think hero i'm
at griffin d and we ass of a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
hero fans make sure you light that page
and share our video and Twitter and
Facebook and all those stuff
you